LEIGHA JARETT: If you
watched our previous video,
you're already familiar with
how BigQuery stores your data.
But how does BigQuery
actually process your data
and execute queries?
Understanding what goes
on behind the scenes
is key to ensuring your
queries will run super fast.
In this video, we'll walk
through the life of a query
and show you how to leverage
the query plan to troubleshoot
and optimize your SQL.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let's begin with an overview
of BigQuery's architecture.
In our last video, we talked
about Google's distributed file
system that stores
BigQuery data, Colossus.
But to actually
compute data, BigQuery
uses Dremel, the query engine.
Here, workers or slots, like
we discussed in our video
on jobs and the
reservation model,
are used to extract
data from storage
and perform aggregations.
To increase the performance,
each of these slots
does work independently
from one another.
Instead of communicating
directly with each other,
they use what we call
the remote memory shuffle
to store intermediary results.
In BigQuery, each shuffled
row can be consumed by slots
as soon as it's
created, which makes
it possible to
execute distributed
operations in a pipeline.
All of this data
movement is facilitated
by Jupiter our super-fast,
Google-scale network.
Now that you understand
the architecture,
let's see what happens inside
of BigQuery when you actually
submit a query to be run.
First off, an API
request will be
sent with all the
details of the query.
To proceed, there's some
level of API processing
that must occur--
for example, authenticating
and authorizing the request,
and building and
tracking metadata
such as the SQL statement, cloud
project, and query parameters.
Next, BigQuery will
perform lexing and parsing.
Lexing refers to the process
of scanning an array of bytes--
in this case, the
raw SQL statement--
and converting that
into a series of tokens.
Parsing is the process of
consuming those tokens to build
up a syntactical tree
representation of the query,
which can be validated
and understood
by BigQuery's software.
While lexing and
parsing are underway,
BigQuery will also perform
catalog resolution.
This basically
means that BigQuery
will resolve references to
entities like tables, views,
procedures, and functions.
As a more fully-formed picture
of the request emerges,
BigQuery begins to
build a query plan.
Here, BigQuery will use
different techniques
to refactor and
improve the query,
including adapting it to run as
a set of distributed execution
tasks.
Once BigQuery has
the plan in place,
it will work through the query
stages in the execution graph.
Besides the slots that perform
the work of the query plan
itself, additional
slots monitor and direct
the overall progress.
Not only will these
slots determine
how the work is
queued and executed,
but they can also leverage
BigQuery's dynamic planning
capabilities to make
on-the-fly adjustments
to the query plan that will
further optimize performance.
Finally, when the query
has finished executing,
the results will be sent
back to you, the user.
Awesome.
So now that you have
a picture of what
happens behind the scenes
when a query is submitted,
let's go a little bit deeper
and see what one of those query
plans actually looks like.
Here, I'm going to
run a simple query
to count the number
of trips that
began at a station with Broadway
in the name against the Citi
Bike data available in
BigQuery's public data sets.
In this first stage of the
query plan, a set of slots
will access the distributed
storage to read in the table.
The input table is
actually made up
of a set of input file blocks.
For each input block, a slot
is needed to process the file,
read, and filter down the rows.
Each worker then
writes one record
into shuffle that contains the
partial count for that input
file.
This second stage here reads
from those shuffle records
as its input and then
sums them together.
It then writes the output
file into a single file,
which becomes accessible as
the results of the query.
In the console, after
you run a query,
you can view the query
plan to see this in action.
In the execution details, we
can see the average and maximum
times each worker spent in the
wait phase, where the engine is
waiting for either slots
to become available
or for a previous stage to
start writing results that it
can begin consuming.
In the read phase, where
the worker is reading data,
either from Colossus
or from shuffle.
In the compute phase,
where the actual processing
takes place, such as evaluating
SQL functions or expressions.
And in the write phase,
where the shuffle
output is written
in the next stage
or in the final output table.
Using the query
execution details,
we can clearly see the different
stages of the query plan,
like we showed before, where
the first stage includes workers
that read, filter, and
aggregate the data,
and then write the
results to the shuffle.
And in the second stage,
we read from the shuffle,
aggregate the partial
results, and then
write out the final results.
In addition to being
available in the console,
the query plan information can
be retrieved through the API
from the job response or
by querying the information
schema.
So what can you actually
do with this information?
First off, the query plan
and timeline statistics
can help you understand
whether certain stages dominate
resource utilization.
For example, a join stage
that generates far more output
rows than input rows can
indicate an opportunity
to filter early in that query.
Additionally, if you notice
a significant difference
between average and maximum
time spent by workers,
that could indicate data skew,
which results in one worker
having much more data to
process than the others.
That can, again, represent an
opportunity to filter early.
Or if there is a lot of
time spent on CPU tasks,
you may want to consider
approximate functions, which
are often within 1%
of the exact function.
Armed with your new
understanding of how BigQuery
executes queries, you're now
ready to dig in and start
troubleshooting your
own SQL statements.
For more details on
specific strategies
on how to optimize
your SQL queries,
stay tuned for our next video.
Thanks for tuning
in to this episode
of "BigQuery Spotlight,"
and remember, stay curious.
[MUSIC PLAYING]